ابناء المخيمات في الشمال السوري يقيمون
بطولتهم ايضا
يتفاعلون معها ويستمتعون بمجرياتهم
اطفال مخيمات عيبه يتطلعوننا بان يكونوا
ابطالا يومانا
نشوف الحرس شلون بصدد ضربات وبيقع بيقلب
بنسوي فرقه وبنقعوا بنلعب هون وبنسوي
نفسها الحارس اللي بيعمل بالمونديال
مع حلول المساء يتوافد ابطال الظهيره
برفقه ذويهم ويكون في صفوف مشجعين
اللعب منهم وبجيب رفقاتها معي انا بتعلم
من الحارس لانه حارس قوي
ورفقاتها بتعلموا من اللعب
في مخيمات نازحين يملكون احلاما كثيرا
يتابعون المباريات وكانهم بين جماهير
الملاعب لديهم منتخباتهم المفضله التي
تستحوذ على اعجابهم
حركات لاعبيها النجوم
كمان رائع حضور عربي مشرف لعب جيد وجميل
وفي تطور
[تصفيق]
باللعبور جيد جدا المنتخب
بعيون المتشوقه وعواطف جياشه ينشدون الفوز
بمنتخب عربي اسعدهم بادائهم الكروي الرائع
وكان لهم نتمناه
وتفاعلوا مع المحفل الرياضي الابرز بعدما
اتيح له من يكون جزء بطوله كاس العالم عمر
الحوراني الجزيره من منطقه المشجعين في
مخيمات النزاحين شماليه سوريا